This is a card from the public library here.
Neighbor. All right thank you. Years.
Here.
Very much
so I was born here in one thousand nine hundred five I was born
on Skillman Avenue where well I was born in a hospital but my family lived on Skillman
Avenue where my mother still lives
today and I think a lot of
the the interesting points of growing up here really became clearer
to myself and to my
friends as we grew up and began to know the experiences of other
people in different neighborhoods and how unique. Ours was it was very unique to grow
up in Italian Williamsburg and the reason I say Italian wings of Earth
is
because Williamsburg is a very large place and there's many different enclaves of different
ethnicities and groups
and the Italian section where we lived was
very unique in that it was somewhat insular.
I can tell you and my friends would definitely corroborate this everyone knew everyone.
I grew up on a block where there were many children
about my age.
And basically we grew up it was almost like a growing up in a very tight knit community
where you know we would be in and out of each other's houses every day everyone knew everyone.
You really couldn't get away with anything. I mean
if if I was home doing something I wasn't supposed to be doing you could be certain that the neighbors.
Would be talking to mom and things like that. There was a lot
of outdoor activity. Meaning that growing
up I guess this cultural kind of everywhere these days because
of video games and the internet but. We were constantly on the street
and playing ball or whatever on the Johnny. Fire hydrant
as Brooklynites might say.
So I think the vivid memories really in general would be very close knit community.
Everyone either was related by blood or marriage
and you know there was a strong sense of camaraderie that
lasts throughout like so
that you could be certain that the vast majority of people
who grew up together. Keep in
touch with their sense of family which is actually a very
cultural thing and it's. For
talian the neighborhood concept is something very unique for Italians.
Even those who have moved away would still consider this their neighborhood.
So that's something that transcends just Williamsburg it's a very cultural thing
for Italians
where especially southern
Italians the fans the family was the one unit that was
trusted and the neighborhood made up like
a network of families. And that would be trusted far and
above any government institution or anything like that. So we kind of took care of each other and.
We're constantly together and really
associated more with neighborhood and family than
with any
other possible identification. So we were from the
neighborhood would be a phrase that would be used frequently.
And with a very specific
meaning like if someone was from the neighborhood it meant they were from a town in
Williamsburg and they there was a immediate connection and immediate camaraderie
there. So. More specific memories
and well just let me give you an
example most of the people that I grew up with on the block whether it was
going to have any or for a while we live in Jackson Street right here in the vicinity of this
library every one of us. To keep in touch whether it be through the Internet
or physically.
You almost exclusively marry someone from the neighborhood.
My wife grew up right across the tree from the library
actually so as we got older and we began to kind of
branch out
and it was then that we began to realize that there was a certain insularity to it
where you know people who grew up in other areas.
Sometimes don't understand the camaraderie and the connection.
And the real sense of identity with each
other I remember I worked with a woman who once said to me you know I grew up in Jackson Heights.
She said if I met someone else from Jackson Heights I probably wouldn't know who they were and if I
did we would not be sitting around. Reminiscing about growing up in Jackson Heights.
Whereas with Williams Very good very
unique you would do that you would immediately connect and you would immediately.
Have a certain bond. Even if you didn't necessarily know the person well.
There's a strong sense of community
there which I think today in
general is kind of lacking whether it be here or anywhere else.
But you for better or for worse
you kind of knew everyone's business on the
block and it was in general it was very much an
open community in
that you know people in and out of each other's houses we had block parties frequently.
So no one was really an outsider.
Maybe maybe you didn't know the people a few blocks away but there was still a connection there because they
were from the neighborhood and you went to the school with them and.
So what I see lacking now just from my perspective like where I live
or even among the children in my school
principal is that sense of connection and that sense of community.
I think that's partially cultural in terms of our popular culture.
You know kids today make play dates that there was no such thing that you just rang
somebodies bell and. When in the house it was just expected.
Whereas today they'll make appointments and they tend to be more inside
and I live in Queens now and
I can honestly say we really we've been there for eleven
years and really don't know the neighbors very well I mean maybe to say
hello
so. But although our children are growing up on that block we my wife and
I discuss a drastic difference in their neighborhood experience from what we
have there. Yes My wife
is my wife is also from the neighborhood here she is Italian.
She is half nobly done and half facility and. So when
my grandfather who was from Naples found out that she was Sicilian he immediately told me
to sleep with one eye open.
He didn't he didn't like.
But by the time he got to know very well not about loving her very
much so we actually met in the
feast in Mount and it's kind of a typical Williamsburg story where we
met in the neighborhood in the feast we knew each other from a distance for years.
You know I remember when she was like seven or eight years old
and. You know I knew her parents before I knew her. So it was a
very typical neighborhood type of
situation. And yes she grew up here as well although
she went to a different grammar school her memories would be very
similar and. You know this particular block where we are right now was where she
would hang out with her friends and.
Just. And she had a very similar experience although a few years younger although in a
different school. She would say the same about the neighborhood
and comradery.
Everywhere. There's a lot of characters in the neighborhood as well they were growing up.
Everyone had a nickname particularly the generations before us.
You know the joke was that if you yelled out the word Anthony. Five hundred people would turn around.
So most of the time people have nicknames and usually they were colorful some of them I probably should
repeat it would give you you know you would know who these people
are and to this
day I know them by their nicknames in some cases they're people I've known for forty years and
I don't know their
first.
So that was a part of the culture of the neighborhood as
well so. So that's really.
You know there was a. I mean I was a
relatively little boy but I
mean there was several times
where. My. My mom was a single mom.
So if I happen to go home and my instruction was to do my homework immediately but instead I was
outside playing ball.
There was no way around the fact that she was going to find that out and she did find out many times because
that the kind of like a Nietzsche arcs of the block in the warmer
weather would always be out watching
us and for good better or worse they would tell Mom everything that you did so
she would know if I
didn't do my best something like that I was I was just outside
playing. She would know what time I
went in to do the homework to try and do it before she got
home the general rule was particularly in the summer the general was once
the street lights went on you start hearing moms out the windows yelling.
So if I was making believe I didn't hear her I was going to get around that because everyone else or.
Yeah there was a lot of that type of thing.
I remember
even in my younger days like maybe eight or nine years old where I was not
yet permitted to cross the
street and if I did with my friends. She found out more than once that I did
so I was a
scuffle.
Here. When I think of the friends that I grew up with it's
about fifty fifty there was
a Over the last few years as we've gotten. Married and started to have children.
Most of us couldn't afford to remain in the area which is really gentrified a
lot in the general trend was for people to move to Middle Village.
So there are a lot of people in Middle Village in my immediate vicinity who are from here. I would
say about fifty percent. Particular stayed
here particularly those who maybe they already own the buildings or they had an
empty apartment in the mom's building.
So I do find myself here in the neighborhood pretty frequently to visit. Even my mom my
in-laws still live here on the street not
devotion yet.
And so I would say about fifty percent of the friends I grew up with still live
in the neighborhood.
But even they will lament how quiet the block is.
There's not many kids playing outside and.
You know the different changes that have taken place and believe it or not some of those Mitri arks
are still around sitting and now they're in their eighty's we thought they were old you know twenty five
thirty years ago now they're in their eighty's but they still sit out on the block and so there's still
a percentage of us.
Yes.
Mt Carmel is kind of been a micrometer was founded in the hundreds for
Italian immigrants.
It was what at the time was called a national church. Meaning that it didn't
have specific geographical boundaries it was for a particular
nationality one of the reasons that was necessary was because in the United States with all the
different immigrant groups.
Different groups were not necessarily always welcome.
So whereas the local parish church may have been predominantly Irish or
say. They really didn't want the Italians and
their you know unique because Allah says them and their statues and their
perceptions and the.
Italians have a very emotional dramatic expression of their religion.
Whereas. The Irish culture
would be a lot more
somber So national churches were founded so growing up we always went
to Mount Carmel Church.
Which was always like that because of that fact was always really central to the Italian
community there were some other
Italian parishes in the area but it was
always particularly because of the famous feast it was always very
central So I was an altar server there and grew up there. Many of my friends went there either to
the school or to the church. So it's been been there as part of my life since
day one.
Yes
my first time I was on the executive
board which is people talk about the Supreme Court being on the executive board of the
feast is the highest honor anybody could be appointed
to I was a Turk. Actually while I was in service when
I was in front of thousands of people proposed to
my
wife thinking that she couldn't say no one thousand people.
Because we had met in the feast and we had our first official conversation the
feast first date sprung to take her to the feast which is free
and so you know we both were volunteers there and I thought it
would be a good idea
to while I was the target. It's difficult to explain but the
churches the pageants of the faeces the Giulio I don't know
how much you know about that
it did you know is a four ton eighty five foot structure
that's carried. Through the feasts and it's it's a very beautiful pageant to see it's
not something you could really discuss. It's something you have to witness to it. Appreciate you
know imagine the Washington Monument just bouncing down the street.
But it's accompanied by a boat that's almost as heavy and then reenacting.
The reenacting to turn return of Sam to his town of
NOLA and he was on a boat so that's the reenactment and the people who read it him with.
Giulio means Lily in Italian so the people greeted him with ours a little so every
year man is chosen
to reenact the Bopara of the Turks so that was my role that
year and that's why I had
the opportunity to publicly
propose that was my way of happen. Saying it.
Absolutely.
Well
the neighbors as I got older and
things began to change in the neighborhood and we began to all of us I
think began to interact more with people from other parts of the neighborhood which
for us seem like other nations we began to realise how unique
our experience was.
At least for someone growing up and then teenagers. You know maybe people in the forty's and fifty's said you
need those similar experiences but our neighborhood was kind of old fashioned even in
the eighty's and
ninety's. So I was very interested in studying that and
appreciating it more and as things started to change. I guess it brings you to a greater appreciation
of what you had.
So I went to
Fordham and I was throwing around different ideas with my mentor. He said you know you
usually wind up your dissertation you want to
writing about yourself and some way shape or
form and we can we got to talking about the feast.
The
most and how it was really a magnet for the young men in the area the young people and.
Mt Carmel is unique in that you would have a lot of men involved in the parish culturally Italian men
generally are not involved in
religion but one of the reasons for that I felt with the feet.
So I studied Italian American popular religion. And the way in
which it kind of incorporate. Young people into the church and into the Catholic
culture that wound up being a dissertation because of
that and it's really that popular religion.
Meaning things like the feasting that the people do that are not necessarily coming
from the institutional church.
That's very unique to Kalyan. Collison and it's one of the
reasons we won the national church
and some of the more traditional groups like the Irish they wanted no part of
that they didn't like the perceptions and you know very dramatic drummer in
the fireworks and Julio
and so that's how we wound up with places.
He's
writing.
Well one of the things that was surprising was as we
interviewed interviewed about one hundred young men particularly women as
well but mostly the majority of them are
men who have different age levels have been involved in the parish and the feast and.
Their experience of the feast really.
Regardless of the hierarchy of where they list
it is
what has been essential in making them part of the
church in other words you know they identify themselves
as Catholics as Italian
Catholics and a certain level of pride there and a certain level of religious practice it doesn't necessarily
mean that
devout but it usually stems from their involvement in the popular religion in
the feast more so than going to a Catholic school more so
than religious education classes. It was their socialization
into the faith through the feast that really affected their lives. Any build Vaughn's and help
build a neighborhood sense of camaraderie and community
that probably helped make
the neighborhood what it was. In the sense that like. My previously mentioned friend who said you know
I grew up in Jackson Heights
and she just doesn't see that come around to read that.
So I think the feast has been a very big part of
that most of them return even if they moved to Queens or an island
at least to be involved in the feast. If not every Sunday. And I think
in many ways that was kind of the glue that made the camaraderie and the whole the neighborhood together for many
years. And we're doing.
To you and that
are so
many yes.
Well
it's interesting everyone ask me that because the joke in the diocese among all the priests is if
you live in Queens Why are you studying for Mount Carmel.
When I was younger I seriously considered becoming a
priest a lot of the priests in the neighborhood were very influential in my life I grew
up basically without a dad and. The priests in Mount
Carmel particularly when I was a kid the pastor was a
huge figure in the neighborhood. It was very
traditional Going back to what we were discussing before
where someone of the neighbor had a
problem being of that southern Italian culture. You didn't go
to psychiatry's you didn't go to the police you didn't go
to you know you went to the priest and he was very much a father figure to the neighborhood.
So as a
young student I seriously was considering becoming a priest even into college.
And then I met my wife and she seduced me and. So I decided not to become
a priest but I still
felt a strong call to
be involved in the church and be active and try to
do you know a little bit more than.
You know the average involvement was something I always felt a strong call to
do and deacons can be married.
So as time went on I was certain that maybe that was what. I should be doing.
And because of our connection to the neighborhood. My wife and I and
my three children.
We always continue to come back here on Sundays to serve it to be
a. First of all because of that family camaraderie that we're talking
about and also because our family still live here too. Coming on Sunday for the pasta
Anyway that's still a big deal in the neighborhood
here. So I asked Mt Carmel to sponsor
me even though I live in the geographical boundaries of another parish in
Queens and so far. Everybody's been OK with that the bishop gave his
OK So God willing I would be as one somewhere doing that. Maybe I would be assigned to my home.
It's a long process a very good one. It's a five year
process because I really had the doctorate in theology needed to get
me some of the classes because I was actually I taught some of those
courses so they were like you don't have to take those so for me it's been a three year
program and there's days where it's intensive two nights a
week class one Saturday I'm on several retreats required per year.
It's been a very positive experience a great great classroom with a lot of great guys
we carpool together. Through each step of the process the
church requires that you
have and this is the word that you have permission so she has to give
permission for you to join the program
just yet. So for the last three years I've been really nice to my wife trying to make sure that
she and then come the day of ordination the
week before she has to meet with the bishop and just to say that. This is not in Perth
a marriage or anything like that and just assign her permission again. So that's been a good
bonding experience this is something that the wives have to go to as well. Retreats and
things and but for the most part it's the guys that go on the classes and retreat.
I think it's helped me and I love the. Ariens of working in Williamsburg.
I'm bringing it's interesting as a deacon you usually involved in the parish where
you live and grew up. So I'm bringing today for example I'm
bringing ashes to people that remember me when I was in diapers
and sometimes that could be a good thing or sometimes you're giving actually to someone and they're like remember
the time I broke my window with a baseball.
So that's that's and I say my mom lives across in the church and bringing her
ashes today because she recently had hip surgery
so it's a nice experience it's kind of like a homecoming in the sense to work with
people that you know but then there's also a great opportunity as the neighborhood changes to try and reach out
to newer people and let them know they're welcome and let them know that there is a place here for them and.
So you want to balance the two. So that's been a great experience so far.
It's.
Something.
Sure
I can only speak specifically to Mount Carmel really. I know a number of the local churches
are trying in different ways to reach out. Mt Carmel which
has trying to balance really really trying to balance the
traditional Italian. Identity that we have but also at the same
time let people know they're
welcome. As the neighborhood began to change. Especially in
the ninety's you know the first wave
of change a lot of artists were coming in so we've tried to
do things that might appeal to them. We've
allowed the pastors allowed. Anything from comic book shows
to just playing of course that people
made. There is a theater company now that the parish has it has put on some excellent
production and. Quality stuff. I mean they don't just get like the
local kid who wants to be in a play I mean they really do auditions and then some quality thing.
Just to try and let people know that they're welcome.
And one of the things that I've been
doing. Is what's called the theology on
tap and basically you have
a talk about a particular topic in religion but at a local
bar and one of the one of the things that Williamsburg does not lack
is so I had to make the sacrifice and sample each bar
and it was difficult it was so and you know some of them a very open they give us
the back room
and it's it's a national program and it's not something that Brooklyn
came up with but.
Actually originated in Chicago but that's been pretty successful in letting people know that
they're welcome we have Sunday night Mass now to appeal to the people who might not be up early in
the sun there and that's been working out pretty well so you do see a lot of new
faces in the church
and basically just to be both welcoming and inviting inviting
in the sense that not just wait for people to come to you
but you know let them know that they're invited to come in and look at things
and I think personally
the
different. Productions that have been put on I think those have
been successful in letting people at least know that we're
not adversarial you
know there's so many new people in the neighborhood
with many of them may or may not have a Catholic background may
have they may not be particularly religious but it's just a sense of letting them know
that you know we're here for you and you're welcome.
I think it was done a good job of trying to balance the
two you know to be a traditional Italian welcoming place in terms of
the feast and. We still have a tiny mass on Sunday there is still a decent population
of Italian speakers who come to that
now but at the same time trying to show everybody that they could be part of the place.
I believe the feast is a tremendous way of doing that because you have thousands of people are just
walking through to see what it's about and make them feel welcome and invite them
in so.
Well
I would say the been many changes some good some not so good
the just generally speaking the population is obviously increased tremendously.
When we were growing up my friends and I sometimes and I hate to say this
but sometimes we would
be hesitant to say we were
from Williamsburg because people associated
with the south side which had a lot of gang activity and drug
problems we when we went to high school I remember my friends discussing the fact that
people didn't know what Williamsburg
was we had absolutely no chain stores of any kind
in Williamsburg there was no Burger King McDonnell's Dunkin Donuts Starbucks nothing.
It was kind of like people didn't know we were
here and for the most part we didn't mind that we were insular
we liked our neighborhood we liked being together and.
So therefore sometimes we would tell people we were from Greenpoint because
we border. The Italian section of Williamsburg bordered on
replying and people generally had a better view of Greenpoint or they at least heard of it.
But now with the changes. It's become trendy it's one train stop from
Manhattan the property values have more than quadrupled.
And now it's a trendy popular thing to say you're from Williamsburg
and the joke that we had was that we knew it was cool. Before anyone else
realized that. You know the population has changed drastically I think one thing that's been lost.
It's good to have the increased value real estate wise it's good
to you know the neighborhood.
I mean the crime was never really a problem but that really hasn't changed
either. It's a lot more difficult to park than it ever
was before and but I think one thing that's kind of been lost
because of the population explosion.
It's been like that sense of community and camaraderie.
Now I look at the block I grew up on a least half the people I don't know.
People kind of keep to themselves. So it's not all
bad but you definitely lose that sense of community and neighborhood.
There is a certain anonymity that's come out of it almost similar to like a
big part of Manhattan something.
My mom would say that the bar on her corner which plays music till two am is not good either
but so I think that sense of community
maybe being lost a little
bit.
You know. I think there's still remnants of a time when
Americans. I think many of the I don't even know that sometimes are
called hipster I don't know I don't want to say
anything sero insulting but many of them seem to have a nice genuine
curiosity about the traditions of the neighborhood that I really haven't come across any
animosity from them.
The feast. Thank God has been preserved and continues to do
well we have some very famous Italian restaurants like the Monte
that continue to
flourish. So I think things have been preserved
this especially in regard to the churches and the
fees. It's still a huge tourist attraction. We get
approximately last year's estimate was over twenty five thousand people during the
course of the festival not necessarily at one time but at least twenty five thousand.
On the day of the Julio we
get almost fifteen ten to fifteen thousand pending on the
weather. So. I mean that's a that's a big
day so I think that has been preserved and hopefully will continue to
be. And like I said it there's been a
genuine friendliness I guess.
Jen they like the quickness of it the artistry
the video is a wonderful example of focal
art. For Italian culture so that's something that they new people tend to be interested in.
In fact the Brooklyn Arts Council did something about our folk art in the manner in which the
Julia was
constructed. So that's been good and I think those things have
been retained and probably will
be. But there is in the parishes have
become commuter parishes in the sense
that as I look around the home like on a Sunday. Probably a quarter of
us are driving in from Middle Village or Glendale or mass the
different parts of Queens which are not far away but it's not the same.
So. Yeah. Madge.
I just think it's very difficult
to express in words the uniqueness of what it was to grow
up in Italian Williamsburg.
It was about a centuries worth of you know immigrants here
from particularly from the turn of the century in the twentieth century and.
One of the most unique things. There is a Facebook group called the
neighborhood and it's basically people reminiscing about growing up in Williams
Italian
Williamsburg and they have different political viewpoints they have different ages they have
different experiences but the
most unanimous aspect of the thing that unites all of them
is over two thousand members on
the page is the
uniqueness of growing up here and.
Positiveness you know it was
just a wonderful experience. They would not give
up if someone said to me you know you can do it all over again to grow up in a very rich
wealthy neighborhood in a mansion.
I wouldn't I wouldn't change it I mean the friends that I grew up with. They're still here with me
and
I wouldn't want to have any other experience as a child and.
So there was just a sense of safety a sense of connection.
Really a sense of family I think that's probably lacking in the average neighborhood today anywhere you go.
So there are still Italian enclaves.
But even they have become more modernized and individualized. And I
think we were very lucky at least my generation to be probably the
last to grow up in Italian Williamsburg
where even my children won't see that beautiful connection to others and.
At least not the same way we
did. Maybe they see it during the feast. But it's something
I would never give up I think is very formative.
More so than any formal education just.
That even today I mean we just people stick together from
Williamsburg
and if the joke. I'm a principal now in the Queen's.
School and it's in Middle Village and the joke is you know.
So who did you hire this week from Williamsburg you know
so kind of that that loyalty to each other
and trying to help each other out and.
That automatic connection and I almost feel bad for my kids because they're
not getting that same neighborhood experience that we have.
So I'm just babbling now right.
My pleasure thank
you.